Hi, my name is Emily. I am a master's student studying clinical psychology at Southampton. I bought the book The Clinical Psychologist Collective to help myself prepare for my first round of doctorate applications and I'm so glad I did. Seeing how others have reflected on their journeys has been so insightful and it's given me a lot to reflect about with my own journey and skills. It's also helped to put things into perspective and reminded me that if I don't get onto the doctorate this year, that's okay. I think the most unexpected pleasure of this book, however, was just how inspirational
嗨，我叫艾米丽。我是南安普顿大学临床心理学专业的硕士生。我买了《临床心理学家合集》这本书，来帮助自己为第一轮博士申请做准备，我很高兴我买了它。看到其他人如何反思他们的旅程，这非常有启发性，也让我对自己的人生旅程和技能有了很多思考。它还帮助我调整了心态，提醒我如果今年没能考上博士，那也没关系。不过，我认为这本书最意想不到的乐趣在于它有多么鼓舞人心
each and every person's journey was, and using these stories as my morning motivation each day has been such a pleasure, I'm almost reluctant to come to the end. Why do we grieve for people we've never even met? If Liam Payne's death hit you hard, or you're still feeling the weight of it now, you're not alone. There's a psychological reason why celebrity losses can feel just as painful as losing someone in your own life.
每个人的旅程都是如此，每天早上用这些故事作为我的动力真是太棒了，我几乎舍不得读完它。为什么我们会为从未谋面的人感到悲伤？如果利亚姆·佩恩的去世让你深受打击，或者你现在仍然感到沉重，你并不孤单。名人离世会让人感到和失去生命中重要的人一样痛苦，这是有心理学原因的。
And if you're a mental health professional, understanding why this happens is key to helping people process these emotions in a healthy way. The way that grief works is we don't just mourn the person. We grieve the memories, the moments, and even the future that we had imagined for that person. Just like when Matthew Perry died, Friends fans weren't just mourning Chandler Bing. the memories, the moments and even the future that we had imagined for that person. Just like when Matthew Perry died, Friends fans weren't just mourning Chandler Bing.
如果你是一名心理健康专业人士，理解为什么会发生这种情况是帮助人们以健康方式处理这些情绪的关键。悲伤的运作方式是，我们不仅仅是在哀悼那个人。我们哀悼的是记忆、时刻，甚至是我们在脑海中为那个人想象的未来。就像马修·派瑞去世时一样，老友记的粉丝们不仅仅是在哀悼钱德勒·宾。记忆、时刻，甚至是我们在脑海中为那个人想象的未来。就像马修·派瑞去世时一样，老友记的粉丝们不仅仅是在哀悼钱德勒·宾。
They were mourning the hope of another season that would never come. For One Direction fans, this loss might feel much bigger than just one person. Many had hoped for a reunion, another album or one last tour, but now that possibility has gone. It reminds me of when Take That broke up in the 1990s. The reaction was so intense that a helpline was set up for devastated fans to call. And in that case, no one had even died. So why does this type of grief feel so real? Why can it linger for months or even years?
他们哀悼的是另一个永远不会到来的季度的希望。对于单向组合的粉丝来说，这种损失可能感觉比失去一个人要大得多。许多人曾希望他们重聚、出新专辑或进行最后一次巡演，但现在这种可能性已经消失了。这让我想起 20 世纪 90 年代 Take That 组合解散的时候。当时的反应非常强烈，甚至为心碎的粉丝设立了求助热线。而在那个案例中，甚至没有人去世。那么，为什么这种悲伤感觉如此真实？为什么它会持续数月甚至数年？
Today we are diving into the psychology of grieving celebrities, how it affects us and what we can do about it. Hi, I'm Dr Marianne Trent, a clinical psychologist and author of the Grief Collective and host of the Aspiring Psychologist podcast. Grief is something I have spent a lot of time supporting people through, both in my clinical work and through my writing. It's also something I've experienced and it is not nice at all. But something I do see time and time again is that grief doesn't always look the way
今天，我们将深入探讨哀悼名人的心理学，它如何影响我们，以及我们能做些什么。嗨，我是玛丽安·特伦特博士，一名临床心理学家，《悲伤合集》的作者，也是《有抱负的心理学家》播客的主持人。悲伤是我在临床工作和写作中花了很多时间帮助人们克服的事情。这也是我经历过的事情，而且一点也不好受。但我一次又一次看到的是，悲伤并不总是以
that people expect it to. It also doesn't only show up when losing a close family member or friend or pet for that matter. It can show up in many different ways, including mourning a public figure that you've never met in person. If you've been struggling with Liam Payne's death or any other celebrity or public figure loss, your feelings are valid. The way that our brains work that doesn't necessarily separate the people that have been a big part of our lives from those who have been in our
人们预期的那样表现出来。它也不仅仅是在失去亲近的家人、朋友或宠物时才会出现。它可以通过许多不同的方式表现出来，包括哀悼一个你从未亲眼见过的人。如果你一直在为利亚姆·佩恩的去世或任何其他名人或公众人物的离世而挣扎，你的感受是合理的。我们大脑的工作方式并不一定能将那些在我们生活中占据重要地位的人与那些在我们
day-to-day lives. And if you are a mental health professional, understanding why celebrity grief can be so profound, this can help support your clients in a more compassionate and informed way. So why do we grieve celebrities? One of the most fascinating things about human psychology is that we can form emotional bonds with people we've never even met. This is what is known as a parasocial relationship, which I know does sound like kind of a complicated term, so let's break it down together. Para means beside or alongside and social refers to our relationship with others. So a parasocial relationship
日常生活中出现的人区分开来。如果你是一名心理健康专业人士，理解为什么名人悲伤会如此深刻，这可以帮助你以更具同情心和更知情的方式支持你的客户。那么，我们为什么要哀悼名人呢？人类心理学中最迷人的事情之一是，我们可以与从未谋面的人建立情感纽带。这就是所谓的准社会关系，我知道这听起来像是一个复杂的术语，所以让我们一起来拆解它。“Para”的意思是旁边或并列，“social”指的是我们与他人的关系。所以，准社会关系
is a one-sided emotional connection that we develop with a public figure. That could be a musician, an actor, an author or even a content creator for that matter. We may never actually directly interact with that person in any way, so they may never know that we exist. But the important factor is that they have been a presence in our life, sometimes for years, maybe even decades. When we think about it, Lee and Payne and One Direction were part of so many people's teenage years. They were there during highs and lows through their music, interviews and live performances. And when someone who's been part of your
是我们与公众人物建立的一种单方面的情感联系。那可能是一位音乐家、演员、作家，甚至是内容创作者。我们可能从未以任何方式与那个人直接互动，所以他们可能永远不知道我们的存在。但重要的因素是，他们一直存在于我们的生活中，有时是几年，甚至几十年。当我们想到这一点时，利亚姆·佩恩和单向组合是许多人青少年时期的一部分。他们通过音乐、采访和现场表演陪伴人们度过了高潮和低谷。当一个曾经是你
life in that way is suddenly gone and in such a traumatic way it can feel deeply personal and deeply distressing. The same thing happened when Matthew Perry died. For so many people Friends was a source of comfort, laughter and nostalgia. It absolutely reminds me of my youth, of carefree times, of friendships and a different time in our lives. His death wasn't just about losing an actor, it was about losing Chandler Bing and all the memories we had made attached to him, his character and the series. Similarly, One Direction fans didn't just lose Liam, they've now lost what feels like a piece of their past, their teenage years and the hope of future reunions
生活的一部分的人突然离去，而且是以如此创伤性的方式，这会让人感到非常个人化和痛苦。马修·派瑞去世时也发生了同样的事情。对许多人来说，《老友记》是安慰、欢笑和怀旧的源泉。它绝对让我想起了我的青春，无忧无虑的时光，友谊以及我们生活中不同的时期。他的去世不仅仅是失去了一位演员，更是失去了钱德勒·宾，以及我们与他、他的角色和这部剧集相关联的所有记忆。同样，单向组合的粉丝不仅仅失去了利亚姆，他们现在失去了一段感觉像是他们过去、青少年时期和未来重聚希望的碎片
that will never happen now. It's a bit like when Take That first broke up in 1996. Fans were devastated and the reaction was so overwhelming that a helpline had to be set up for fans struggling to cope. And this was when nobody had died, they'd just split up and there could still have been a chance that they would one day reunite. There could well have been that hope with Liam Payne and with the 1D band but of course with Robbie Williams and the rest of Take That they perhaps needed that time apart to grow, to heal and to eventually reunite. Many One Direction fans might have been hoping for that same thing for the band but of course when a member dies that no longer
现在永远不会发生了。这有点像 1996 年 Take That 第一次解散时。粉丝们非常崩溃，反应如此强烈，以至于不得不为难以应对的粉丝设立求助热线。而当时并没有人去世，他们只是分开了，而且未来仍有可能重聚。对于利亚姆·佩恩和单向组合，人们可能也曾有过那种希望，但当然，随着罗比·威廉姆斯和 Take That 其他成员的离开，他们也许需要那段分开的时间来成长、治愈并最终重聚。许多单向组合的粉丝可能也曾为乐队抱有同样的希望，但当然，当一名成员去世时，这就不再
becomes possible and can lead to grief as a result of that. And that's a really tough thing to process. I want to break down a concept that might again feel or sound a bit scary and a bit big and that's the concept of disenfranchised grief. And if we were to kind of look at that together, it's one of the reasons why this kind of celebrity grief feels quite complicated actually. Because it's not always recognized or validated by others. So disenfranchised means it's unrecognized or dismissed by society or others. And the grief is the emotional response to that loss. So disenfranchised grief is what happens
成为可能，并因此导致悲伤。这是一件非常难以处理的事情。我想拆解一个可能再次让人感到或听起来有点可怕和宏大的概念，那就是“被剥夺的悲伤”。如果我们一起审视它，这是这种名人悲伤感觉相当复杂的原因之一。因为它并不总是得到他人的认可或验证。“被剥夺”意味着它被社会或他人忽视或否定。而“悲伤”是对这种损失的情感反应。所以，被剥夺的悲伤就是当你
when you are mourning or grieving, but people around you don't necessarily see it as a real grief. So for example, if you had lost a family member, a friend or a pet, most people would tend to offer you their condolences and their sympathy. They might check in on you and acknowledge your pain, ask how they can help. But when a celebrity dies, they might check in on you and acknowledge your pain, ask how they can
哀悼或悲伤时，周围的人并不一定认为这是一种真正的悲伤。例如，如果你失去了家人、朋友或宠物，大多数人往往会向你表示哀悼和同情。他们可能会关心你，承认你的痛苦，询问他们能如何提供帮助。但当名人去世时，他们可能会关心你，承认你的痛苦，询问他们能如何
help. But when a celebrity dies, people might dismiss that grief and say things like, but you didn't even know them. It's not like they were part of your family. Or why are you so upset? This can make you feel like you shouldn't be grieving or that your emotions are somehow invalid or unwelcomed. The ugly truth about grief is that it isn't just about losing someone you knew personally, it's about losing that connection that mattered to you. And why might mental health professionals feel this grief in an intense way? Something I find really interesting is that even people who may not have been a One
提供帮助。但当名人去世时，人们可能会否定这种悲伤，说些诸如“但你甚至不认识他们。他们又不是你的家人。或者你为什么这么难过？”之类的话。这会让你觉得你不应该感到悲伤，或者你的情绪在某种程度上是无效或不受欢迎的。关于悲伤的丑陋真相是，它不仅仅是关于失去一个你亲自认识的人，而是关于失去那个对你很重要的联系。为什么心理健康专业人士会以强烈的方式感受到这种悲伤？我发现一件非常有趣的事情是，即使是那些可能不是单向组合
Direction fan still might have felt really sad about Liam's death. Why could this be? I think being a mental health professional or just being a really empathetic human, we can really connect to and feel the weight of someone's struggles, perhaps their untapped potential or the tragedy of their circumstances. Often with mental health professionals I think it's also that sense of I really wish something, someone or maybe even I could have helped them. This makes me think about the same thing happening when Amy Winehouse died. People weren't just mourning her music, they were mourning the struggles that she went through and
粉丝的人，可能仍然对利亚姆的去世感到非常难过。这可能是为什么呢？我认为作为一名心理健康专业人士，或者仅仅是一个非常有同理心的人，我们真的可以与某人的挣扎、他们未被开发的潜力或他们处境的悲剧产生共鸣并感受到其重量。对于心理健康专业人士，我认为这通常也是一种“我真的希望某事、某人，甚至我自己能帮助他们”的感觉。这让我想起艾米·怀恩豪斯去世时发生同样的事情。人们不仅仅是在哀悼她的音乐，他们是在哀悼她所经历的挣扎和
the hope that she might one day overcome them. And the tragedy is that her life was cut short at the age of 27. For Liam Payne too, there's that sense of what if. What if he'd been able to get the support that it seems that he clearly needed? What if things had turned out differently? He'd got a chance to watch his little boy grow up. And what if he'd lived to make the changes, to continue his solo career and or heal enough to be able to reconnect with One Direction 2?
她有一天可能会克服它们的希望。悲剧在于她的生命在 27 岁时就戛然而止。对于利亚姆·佩恩来说，也有那种“如果”的感觉。如果他能得到他显然需要的支持会怎样？如果事情的结果不同会怎样？他本有机会看着他的小男孩长大。如果他能活着做出改变，继续他的个人事业，或者治愈到足以能够与单向组合重新联系，那会怎样？
All of those what ifs, the jagged edges, what we call the yearning and the bargaining in grief can make it really hard to process and mean that it just doesn't lay flat. So how do you cope with celebrity or parasocial grief? If you are struggling with Lee and Payne's death or any other celebrity or public figure loss, here are a few things that might help. Acknowledge your feelings. Your grief is valid. You don't have to justify that to anyone. Talk about it. Share memories, discuss their impact and connect with others who understand too. You might like to channel it into something positive. Listen discuss their impact, and connect with others who understand too. Number three, you might like to channel it
所有这些“如果”、那些尖锐的边缘，我们在悲伤中所说的“渴望”和“讨价还价”，都会使处理悲伤变得非常困难，意味着它不会轻易平复。那么，你如何应对名人或准社会悲伤呢？如果你正在为利亚姆·佩恩的去世或任何其他名人或公众人物的离世而挣扎，这里有一些可能有帮助的事情。承认你的感受。你的悲伤是合理的。你不需要向任何人证明这一点。谈论它。分享记忆，讨论他们的影响，并与同样理解的人联系。你可能想把它转化为积极的事情。听讨论他们的影响，并与同样理解的人联系。第三，你可能想把它转化为
into something positive. Listen to their music, donate to a cause they supported, or write about what it meant to you. Number four, it's the same for all grief. We need to be able to give yourself time. Grief doesn't have a set timeline, and it's okay to still feel emotional months later. A celebrity grief is real because as humans we have emotions and our brains
积极的事情。听他们的音乐，向他们支持的事业捐款，或者写下它对你意味着什么。第四，这对所有的悲伤都是一样的。我们需要能够给自己时间。悲伤没有固定的时间表，几个月后仍然感到情绪化也是正常的。名人悲伤是真实的，因为作为人类，我们有情感，而我们的大脑
don't always differentiate between people we know and people we don't and that is the nature of the parasocial grief which can be so easily invalidated in others around you. We can even invalidate ourselves too. If you are struggling with grief or if you'd like to be able to understand how to support people who are grieving, please do check out the Grief Collective, stories of life loss and learning to heal. People tell me that it really helps them to understand themselves and to understand why people grieve, how they grieve and it includes 54 stories written by real people about their experiences with grief for a variety of reasons. Thank you for watching. If you found this content helpful I would love it if you would
并不总是区分我们认识的人和我们不认识的人，这就是准社会悲伤的本质，它很容易被周围的人否定。我们甚至会否定自己。如果你正在与悲伤作斗争，或者如果你想了解如何支持正在悲伤的人，请查看《悲伤合集：生命损失与学习治愈的故事》。人们告诉我，它真的帮助他们了解自己，了解人们为什么悲伤、如何悲伤，它包含了 54 个由真实的人撰写的关于他们因各种原因经历悲伤的故事。感谢观看。如果你觉得这些内容有帮助，我很乐意你
subscribe if you're watching on YouTube. Drop a like, drop a comment, let's support one another in the comments, let me know why you're watching and what it has evoked for you. Please do consider sharing this episode with someone that you think might benefit from it. Please, obviously, if you do feel that you can't keep yourself safe and that life doesn't feel like it's worth living, please do reach out to your local mental health service or your local doctor. Grief might feel like it will never end but I promise it can be processed so that it lays flatter and so that life feels more worth living again in future. Hi, I'm Max, and I work as an Assistant Psychologist in the Learning Disability Service in West Yorkshire. Like most people working in psychology, I'm slowly but surely working myself up to
订阅（如果你是在 YouTube 上观看的话）。点个赞，留个言，让我们在评论区互相支持，让我知道你为什么观看，以及它唤起了你什么样的感受。请考虑与你认为可能从中受益的人分享这一集。当然，如果你确实觉得无法保证自己的安全，觉得生活不值得活下去，请务必联系当地的心理健康服务机构或当地医生。悲伤可能感觉永远不会结束，但我保证它可以被处理，这样它就会变得平复，让生活在未来感觉更值得活下去。嗨，我是马克斯，我在西约克郡的学习障碍服务中心担任助理心理学家。像大多数从事心理学工作的人一样，我正在缓慢但肯定地朝着
that seemingly impossible goal of getting onto the clinical doctorate. With that end goal in mind, I thought I'd have a look at what's out there and see what books might be helpful for us. I came across Marianne's book, The Clinical Psychologist Collective, and decided that this would be a great buy for me to help me on my journey. I found Marianne's book really informative, most insightful. I especially liked how the stories reassured me that you don't need to be academically perfect to become a psychologist and that as long as you have good interpersonal skills such as compassion and empathy, you will get there.
那个看似不可能的目标——考上临床博士学位——努力。考虑到这个最终目标，我想看看外面有什么，看看哪些书对我们有帮助。我偶然发现了玛丽安的书《临床心理学家合集》，并决定这对我的旅程来说是一次很棒的购买。我发现玛丽安的书非常翔实，非常有启发性。我特别喜欢这些故事如何让我确信，成为一名心理学家并不需要学术上完美，只要你拥有良好的社交技能，如同情心和同理心，你就能做到。
I would highly recommend this book to all aspiring psychologists and also those who want to know a bit more about the world of clinical psychology and maybe want to work in that field one day. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我强烈向所有有抱负的心理学家，以及那些想更多地了解临床心理学世界并可能希望有一天在该领域工作的人推荐这本书。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。